[Musique]
qu'elle nous présente ici le titanoboa
la représentation du titanoboa où les
enfants vont s'amuser à parcourir le
chemin à l'intérieur du titanoboa c'est
un serpent qui avec lui il ya 60
millions d'années environ en amérique du
sud
c'est un serpent qui mesurait environ 15
mètres pour un mètre de diamètre c'est
assez impressionnant on se demande
comment une telle espèce a pu exister
sur terre donc pour l'instant on
continue à travers la galerie on va se
diriger vers la plus petite voiture
produite en masse au monde voilà celle
ci aussi va être assez intéressante
pis au pif ici donc voici sept heures
cette petite voiture ici on peut en
faire le tour
[Musique]
donc ici dans cette exposition vous avez
des choses vraiment intrigante vraiment
fascinante
vous allez vouloir en savoir plus sur la
science derrière tous ces objets ses
animaux ses histoires aussi que raconte
l'ambiance fébrile dans ses dessins web
wiplie entertainment et sayus note anne
thériault ont fait un fabuleux travail
également de collection suite à auburn
me plaît pour continuer toute cette
collection d'objets d'histoire des
dessins également qu'ils ont été
poursuivis
[Musique]